[Applauso]
ciao a tutti e oasi nuova challenge e
flying balls cinque colori di colla e
glik per il momento in questo simili
elezioni che abbiamo già fatto di flag
tre colori di colla usa in cinque colori
di glitter però questa volta ci saranno
sia le colle che sono coloranti pc sia
il glitter e la ruota severa e colori
come potete vedere nella ruota non c'è
scritto niente perché la multa servirà
solo a scegliere i colori in più vedete
che ad esempio di blu ci sono varie
tonalità e anche nei glitter l'altra
persona dovrà scegliere quale tonalità
dovremo usare di quel colore fra il
migliore allora sono decidere se
prendere il colorante o i glitter nella
rotta dove ci sono le palline che
capitano le palline dovremmo prendere il
leader di quel colore se invece non c'è
niente vuol dire chiedo per stendere il
colorante di quel colore fra violano
team in realtà sono team argento perché
sono più argentata però non una paletta
rigettata quindi ho preso la qualità
viola che il gruppo più blu scuro 3
maggio potete votare
siete entrati mettetevi comodi prendete
i pop corn e lasciate in bella stato un
bel live se volete vedere altre
challenge con la ruota e iniziamo subito
la forbice sasso che un soldo carta
qualche mese fa vediamo un po che colore
mi capita
speriamo bene speriamo rosso rosso non è
proprio un colore non lo so non abbiamo
mai fatto dello slide di colore rosso
quindi per no è no allora sperano il
rosso quad a mutare il grosso ecco
quanto non è rosso colorante alimentare
perché in un gioco alpini so già che il
michelin mostra tipo rossi sangue ma
dipende da te mi capita dopo aperto per
te
[Musica]
luca prossimi ferrero tanto da dover
aiuto per scegliere la tonalità quindi
vediamo che fortune per un click
[Musica]
sono anche questi questa più chiara
eccoli qua allora vediamo un po come si
stanno provando l'inter
[Musica]
sei stato fortunato si mischia non si
vedono tanto la mettiamo allora mettiamo
tanta da tra pa e gruppo perché il rosa
è chiaro non si vede la punta ala senza
festa che prima è carinissimo teniamo il
mio allora rischiamo ma cosa e sonangol
a prof four e potrebbe diventare un rosa
chiaro no però sembra sangue dai quasi
sistos che rendo pochettino da spero che
mi capiti un altro colore blu caino e
che poi si mischino bene assieme ai
giocatori
[Musica]
no veramente bravi non si può mandare
lettere non voleva elementi che c'è
sotto
come avete potuto vedere il verde non
abitare a me non capito al primo turno
che avevo al secondo strano però mi è
capitato e batte al primo turno no
veramente apparenze sfiga c'è come ci
sarà verde il rosso parole il colore
diventa allora i canoni mette ancora un
po di più
no basta ciò mi è bastato guarda ma so
già che perderò
[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora io sto a diventà di rimanere di
tema rosa quindi di mettere solo poche
gocce di roma non è giusto dire di
mentre tanto anch'io ne ho messo tanto
non hai permettere tar non hai messo
tanto verde quindi no non mi metto lo
metti
quando sei watch anemone e che c'era mai
mettere più belle terrazze mia perché
non è messo più verde allora guai a chi
nome su un tacco in esso si gocce di
rosso di capi di chissà chi insomma
chissà chi vincerà
mamma mia ma non è bello quanto accaduto
è bello questo slam tra esperienze rosa
cosa è stupendo
cosa vi donano capitale fra una
cacchetta questo verde galleggiante
velate che rimane più sopra rimane in
superficie
bene o guerra lo posso anche ricoprire
non succede niente
guarda sto fondando rimasta solida
va bene mi schiavo
[Musica]
il motivo è stranissimo spesso per
strano ma io sto diventando una sorta di
celeste ma che è grigio no forte di bard
e acqua se l'acqua sporca mischiato col
rosso sto diventando una sorta di bard e
acqua mi dispiace per te verde non ha
vinto questa volta cioè a natale ci sono
dunque riflessi verdi ma forse se vi
capita un altro colore
non ci sarà più verde vita ha fatto
camera che ben si sa i glitter tu puoi
scegliere quali io scelgo questi quindi
una sorta di viola rosso scuro spero che
salvino news la mamma
bellissimi siamo lo stesso rando e anche
per evitare mai girati alla piccola
coppa nazionale
[Musica]
per far ciò che fortuna come sempre te
il più fortunato io e sfortunata fa
quindi pallone da questo darà un tocco
bellissimo il mio slime ancora tanto
all'altro a quello on line google e con
i glitter ne sarà ancora più evidente
rosa è un po vado mi chiamano solito
fortunato ma che bello questo rosso su
mobilitato e stupendo però gol
vediamo vediamo non è ancora finita ci
mancano due turni ancora al momento più
bello il mio magari ti capita un colore
bottino magari no del diavolo
no no vediamo se eletto per cambiare il
colore questo sligo dell'inter dice il
tenente così per la melma a quelle che
bella vita
tra l'altro non è molto verde un po
patrolio azzurro metallizzato bello però
con il dritto twitter stanno un po
scomparendo in superficie
male almeno il mio incolore bello
intenso su tutto trasparente l'incontro
è stupendo vedremo
il colore è cambiato moltissimo
effettivamente ho paura che diventerà il
credito come quell'altro nella sfida di
non fare il rumore challenge a competere
col mio detti e dopo non può davvero
competere quanto è bello mai toccato
chiamate ok dai visto che mi capiti
questo è il colorante viola ma il giallo
così insieme al lupo fatto male glitters
league è successo così corso momento
galaxy vediamo quali segni vita celesti
questi beni
mi piace questo celeste gara oppure
favorendone non ci avevo pensato lei
preferito ben coloni io vedo molto bravo
con die
[Musica]
anche tu è un malessere del vede però
dove sono contento solo quelli glitter
professore lei io ma lui ora vediamo
quali sono i più brutti
questi sono i verbi torto corrotto non
sto tanto bene a tutta
direi questo oscuro metti metti vediamo
un po tutti insieme le cose
vediamo come sicuro che gli darà un
tocco speciale non mi dire anche questo
di natale che furbacchione proprio il
mezzo è nono di più abbordabili basta e
arriva al babbo slime babbo natale
abbiamo gidon live da un tocco perfetto
stanno benissimo queste biglietto verde
è invece si guarda lo valorizzano crede
e continua ad essere trasparente mentre
il mio ha un colore vivacissimo non è
vero il vino è bellissimo e molto
delicato il mio flime mentre il tuo
invece che un accozzaglia di colore nero
vediamo cosa ti capita l'ultimo turno
però proprio korea io dei bellissimi
glitter azzurri bto cui si stanno wax e
non capisco perché spariscono così in
fretta però guarda un po che il riflesso
riflesso rosa una galassia di stelle
colorate ma vedo quando l'ultimo turno
speriamo che la migliore del mondo
perché mi fortuna per una volta il
giallo giallo giallo nuovo lecito
ricordare i segni alla messa che sarà
proprio in viale tica devi mettere
queste gli azzurri non potevate low cost
anzi noi 60 maledetta dura sapevi perché
così non posso fare a farlo mature a dar
live
il riparati bello click
non è vero il mio di capitale che lo
vedremo la verde vediamo quali era che
ti amo corsetto capi vogliamo come sarà
il più bello alla fine tanto rimane
uguale mani crediti perché secondo me
sarò berlo uguale possiamo subito da
pulci kant
a questi mesi tanti meriti visti
tantissimi questi riferimenti pochi è
noto chi perché non mi risulta tutto
questo vedremo quale sarà il più bello
una volta attivato semplice sono il mio
allora come potete vedere io ho sempre
gli stessi glitter e azzurri ma non vuol
dire niente perché anzi diventa ancora
più galazzi ancora più grazia guerra
alla fine il colore è una sorta di color
galassia metallizzato grigio no e tv
vedremo una volta attivo colore
bello per me ora procediamo certi vari
castris line e vogliamo bene e potrebbe
votare da una bici per le più belle sia
per l'aspetto che per sony sta poco da
dire guarda cosa più bello già dal
colore si vede ma è bellissimo blu viola
galatino il mio trascorso foto e i
glitter verdi tra l'altro il lido non
tantissimi anni parla mai dimostrata
benissimo e dove ora ci devi farmi
vedere il mio streaming volevo ricordare
che il mio bellissimo libro con tanti
bellissimi sligo ma non solo anche fai
da te e challenge è ancora scontato
swanson vi fosse un piccolo spoiler
apro una pagina a caso se linking
descrizione se volete prenderlo e ora
rena e quaglia l'aima lampi di colore
venuto qui li stimo perché è una sorta
di blu metallizzato e poi si vedono
tutti gli ips quindi direi che può
sembrare una sorta di galaxy
[Musica]
super estendibile super morbida e si
vedono i glitter blu e viola quindi che
utilizzate da una ghezzi
vediamo ora quello di vita le vere colpe
punto il mio slime guardate verde con
lucidissimo verde ma e rock
scusate fabio slide de rosa quindi fitto
al verdi e bellissimo trasparente ancora
deve riposare un pochettino per
diventare completamente trasparente ma è
stupefacente super allungabile
quell'inter verdi sul rosa danno un
aspetto meraviglioso facciamo il nostro
amato farlo meglio è arrivato e affinità
che sentiamo anche i rumori
hai imparato a fare il porting il tuo
non li fa questi bei rumori ei vestiti
più belli non c'è storia
non c'è storia vinco io
sentiamo le bolle
la spianata anche con le bolle e mi ruba
la scena
sto ancora ma stato quindi guardate il
valore che bellissimo sono riuscito a
tenerlo su un unico colore
ciò nonostante fosse riuscito il rosso e
il verde come glitter quindi guardate
che è stupendo non c'è niente da fare
questa volta si vota noi è una data che
ormai stiamo lì a fianco è che io cerco
il mio
che carini però dai tre usciti molto
cari 72 blu metallizzato e rosa chiaro
la donna lo slime attaccato troppo
bellino dbs troppo nel pochi che adesso
ha detto che imparato spi di sicuro
ottobre morea big one time allora vi
lascio cosa sondaggio in cui potete
guardare servizio mese ho vinto vitale e
ora vi lasciamo quattro cartellini se
puoi cliccare per vedere le nostre altre
sale sui nostri altri slime video
divertenti chi carmela che preferite un
bagno ciao